120.000 عامل في قطاع تكنولوجيا عالميه تم
او سيتم الاستغناء عن خدمتهم خلال العام
الجاري حتى منتصف نوفمبر نحو 50% من القوه
العامله لتر تم تصريحهم بعد ايام من اتمام
الى الماسك صفقه استحواذه على منصه
التغريدات
11,000 موظف او نحو 13% هو عدد الموظفين
الذين تنوي متى الاستغناء عنهم في جميع
انحاء العالم وهي اول عمليه تسريحت جماعي
في تاريخ الشركه
10,000 موظف تخطته امازون لتسريحهم لحسب
تقرير صادر عن عده صحف ومئتان موظف من
شركه نحو الف موظف وعدده الموظفين الذين
استغنت عنهم مايكروسوفت في جميع انحاء
العالم ويقال ان السبب هو تراجع مبيعات
ويندوز لاجهزه الكمبيوتر واخيرا تخطط انتر
لتسريح 20% من الموظفين مع انخفاض شحنات
الربع الثالث من اجهزه الكمبيوتر خلال
العام بنحو 15% مقارنه ب2021 ايضا 20%
كانت نسبه الموظفين الذين صرحتهم سناب شات
بعد الخسائر الكبرى بسبب تراجع الاعلانات
اما بالنسبه لنفلكس فكانت الاقل تصريحا
حيث فقد نحو 450 من موظفيها عملهم في
الفتره الماضيه